my name is NaN foo in Chinese none means
men and a fool means a pillar
my family had hoped for a boy who would
grow up to be the pillar of the family
and when I turned out to be a girl they
named me nan so anyway I was born in
1985 six years before China announced
his one-child policy right after I was
born the local officials came and
ordered my mom to be sterilized
my grandpa stood up to the officials
because he wanted a grandson to carry on
the family name
eventually my parents were allowed to
have a second child but they had to wait
for five years and pay a substantial
fine gorian up my brother and I was
surrounded by children from a one-child
families
I remember feeling a sense of shame
because I had a younger brother I felt
like our family did something wrong for
having two children at the time I didn't
question where this sense of shame and
guilt came from a year and a half ago I
had my own first child it was the best
thing ever happened in my life becoming
the mother gave me a totally new
perspective on my own childhood and they
brought back my memories of early life
in China
for the past three decades everyone in
my family had to apply for a permission
from the government to have a child and
I wondered what it was like for people
who lived under the one-child policy so
I decided to make a documentary about it
one of the people I interviewed was the
Midwife who delivered all of the babies
born in my village including myself she
was 84 years old when I interviewed her
I asked her do you remember how many
babies you delivered throughout your
career she didn't have a number for
deliveries she said she had performed
60,000 forced abortions and
sterilizations sometimes she said a
late-term fetus would have survived an
abortion and she would have kill the
baby after delivering that she
remembered how her hands would tremble
as she did the work
her story shocked me when I set out to
make the film I expected it would be a
simple story of perpetrators and victims
people who carried out the policy and
people who are living with the
consequences but that wasn't what I saw
as I was finishing my interview with the
Midwife
I noticed an area in her house that was
a decorated with elaborate homemade
flags and each flag has a picture of a
baby on it this reflects that was sent
by families whom she helped to treat it
their infertility problems she explained
that she'd had enough of performing
abortions and a sterilization that the
only work she did now was to help
families having babies she said she was
a full of guilt for carrying out the
one-child policy and she hoped that by
helping families having babies she could
counteract what she did in the past it
became clear to me she too was a victim
of the policy every voice was telling
her that what she did was right and
unnecessary for China's survival and she
did what she thought was right for her
country I know how strong that message
was it was everywhere around myself when
I grew up it was printed on the matches
playing cards textbooks posters the /
began the praising the one-child policy
was everywhere around us and so were the
threats against a disobeyin heir
the message seeped into our minds so
much so that I grow up feeling
embarrassed for having a younger brother
with each people I filmed I saw how
their minds and hearts can be influenced
by the propaganda and how their
willingness to make sacrifices for the
greater good can be twisted into
something very dark and tragic China is
not the only place where this happens
there is no country on Earth where
propaganda isn't present and in
societies that are supposed to be more
open and free than China it can be even
harder to recognize what propaganda
looks like a hides in plain sight as
news reports TV commercials political
campaigning and in now social media
feeds it works to change our minds
without our knowledge every society is
vulnerable to accept him propagandas
choose and no society where propaganda
replaces truth can be truly free thank
you
[Applause]